but yeah so look F7 was kind of possible  but instead Magnus goes Queen G6 and  sacrifices The Exchange like this what  is this did he miss  no he can't miss this no because then he  would uh he would take the pawn instead  yeah  no he he might want to have their 95  check on the ball I won't take with the  Knight or what  let's see how fast he reacts now  he missed it I missed it  clearly missed it  exactly terrible  so this is very likely not to end one  one yeah  yeah look at look at magnus's face I  mean because at least he could get this  position with the pawn without the pawn  on G4 yeah  yeah  exactly  wow  that would still be a game for sure  wow big moment for vladis the Vladimir  uh